uh welcome all lovely to see you here
uh nick jonas an actual american star in
the studio
actual yeah actual but you you live here
now
kind of yeah uh my wife and i uh had to
kind of relocate she's shooting here
so we've been here since october uh and
i've been back and forth a bit uh to the
u.s but
it's been lovely yeah what a great time
to get to know what a great time
has it been lovely global pandemic made
it interesting to say the least but
it's been nice and uh happy to be here
with you things look a little different
than they did last year when we were
here
yes you know you were like our last stop
before we went home
and then all of the world shut down that
this was it yeah it's your fault yeah
and you and your lovely wife bianca
you're very kind of public as a couple
has the nickname the couple name that
priyanka came up with
has it taken off well it's i don't know
if we're allowed to say it on tv
you can because it's your couple name
the nickname i mean it's it's
i liked like something with you know
nick
yonka if that's our they called a ship
name
right yeah but she she really preferred
prick
yeah i don't think that's gonna work no
um but not if you're living in london
you can't just be prick
that's what i'm saying yeah i think it
would make you feel better if people
shouted it at you
hey you know oh a couple names
great
who won that prick
[Music]
you